do you have sleepiness after you eat
let's talk about why that is and what to
do about it now they call that a food
coma or post perennial samulans or maybe
even a siesta
but what you have to realize it's not
normal for you to be tired after you eat
because you're getting fuel right you're
supposed to have more energy but why do
people get tired well mainly because
they're doing high carb in fact i used
to use carbs to help my sleeping because
i had such a sleeping problem i used to
consume a pint of ben and jerry's ice
cream right before bed for a very long
time and it would just put me right out
i would go right to sleep of course i'd
wake up all puffy and feeling funky and
irritable and then i would keep the
cycle going over and over and over
because every time i did it it affected
my blood sugars then late at night i
would crave carbs okay
now i've done all the videos on this but
i wanted to do this one specifically
talking about
keto you started keto you're doing
intermittent fasting
and you're still tired what's going on
it could be that you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid in your stomach so you
could just take some apple cider vinegar
or obtain hydrochloride as a supplement
when you eat
that might help but it's usually not the
big problem now it also could be that
your your cells because you have insulin
resistance are just not able to pull in
the nutrients and the fuel but it's
probably true but it's not actually the
thing that's making you tired
if you're not getting nutrients and
you're not getting fuel you're going to
feel like you're not satisfied like you
need to eat something else but you
usually are not going to be tired the
real reason why you're tired
involves insulin resistance but it has
to do with high
insulin because when the insulin is high
it blocks certain brain chemicals that
are supposed to keep you awake
so it's really the high insulin that's
causing this problem but wait a second i
thought lowering your carbs is going to
lower insulin and i just started keto
that's true but there's two things that
increase your insulin number one it's
the carb number two it's eating
you just ate
and eating triggers insulin and the
problem is you've had insulin resistance
for so long
that it's going to take some time to
correct the high levels of insulin
that's occurring because you still have
insulin resistance so even if you don't
eat carbs
eating
triggers
insulin
okay so what can we do well number one
you need to start doing intermittent
fasting right why because eating less is
going to make you more awake and eating
makes you hungry which then triggers
fatigue so if we skip the breakfast that
would be a very smart thing to do okay
just do two meals and start to squish
them together slowly so you can fast
longer because you're going to find out
you have more energy when you're fasting
you're going to have more energy when
you're not eating because you're not
triggering this mechanism so intimate
fasting is vitally important a lot of
people that just started keto they're
not including intermittent fasting
enough and so this is why they still are
tired also make sure that you keep your
carbs low
okay so just be aware of that and look
at your carbs and make sure they're
within the range that you need to do
number three moderate protein you're
going to find out the more protein you
do the more tired you're going to be
because a high protein meal will make
you tired now if you combine the high
protein with a high carb you're really
going to get tired as in thanksgiving
which is the starch and the protein
together just will put you out it's not
the tryptophan it's the combination of a
starch with protein but a large amount
of protein can make you tired so just do
a moderate amount
number four give it time it takes
between one to three months to be keto
adapted okay
that means you're really getting insulin
resistance under control and you're able
to uh go from one meal to the next
without being hungry and that's a big
indication that it's working now in the
meantime you can do things to speed up
your insulin resistance and one thing
because this involves
feeling sleepy is just to try to get a
little bit more sleep another 30 minutes
will help you a simple way to do that
would be to go to bed a little earlier
take vitamin b1
i usually get my b1 through nutritional
yeast take that right before bed and
vitamin d3 especially during the winter
so vitamin d3 right before bed will help
you sleep you should give it a try and
see for yourself
all right thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next video
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website
where you can upload your success story
so you can help inspire others